yeah oh guess who i listened to
country-wise
morgan wallin no uh chris stapleton
wow legend you win not gonna i
i'm in yeah i'm in i was thoroughly
impressed
so uh i've just cycled this music i
can't remember anymore
which one is your favorite uh specifics
i just let it ride because it was just
that good yeah he has some good jazz
he's got some really good jams you're
cruising around in your jeep listen to
that
no no oh no you're not getting you're
not gonna bump it like that not yet
oh okay you know you've got to warm up
you're not there yet i'm not there yet
it's still oasis and you're only in your
home and you're probably saying you're
home yeah the privacy of my home
let me get comfortable there first and
then i'll take it outside
take it on the street i see what you
he's really good though so good his
guitar playing is great yeah
amazing chris is the one that did the
song with uh
justin timberlake too yeah say something
right you heard that
chris stapled to say something i'm
giving up on you
nope nope that's not him i like say
something with a drake and timberland
hold on no chris elton and uh justin
timberlake dude
a banger thank you so much dude yeah
he's really
where's he from look to this i think
because he's he's wrote a song tennessee
no and i just guess i don't know though
that's the one i looked up to country
music's the only guys can get away with
wearing baseball caps at
i know that's just major like dressed
like the undertaker at wrestlemania
[Music]
this isn't it i respect it all the way
that just gave me chills when he opened
that no his video say something's
ridiculous
yeah like he's his voice is just like uh
i don't know
like it's a dirty angel it's a powerful
like a dirty angel dirty angel is that
what he says
that's what i call him oh that's i think
that's country dirty angel
yeah is that it it's great
is so good
now come on bro and sync was all
right he dropped his solo album
oh was it justified uh no it's just
self-titled cry me a river
it wasn't called justified i thought it
was self-titled
what was his first time it might be
so talented yeah
yeah so for pharrell did that whole
album yep he did produced it yeah
you know originally it was for prince
right no no uncle jackson yep
mj wow but yeah didn't like it and so
gave it to timberlake timberlake
senorita i feel for you
come on come on now you ever seen it was
he called justify
yes it was justified yeah i know yeah um
did you you ever seen him live or
anything justin timberlake no but i
would go to i'd be
front row oh front say left front
row dude he comes i'm buying his tickets
let's do it i'm with you justin if
you're troublesome
right maybe wait wait wait wait wait
wait double date
i thought you said double dig i thought
i thought you said double digits
he's a good actor too well let's not go
too far
he was good no alcohol
damn that me up even more because
yeah
i didn't like him at all in that movie
honestly you're a piece of yeah
you're a piece of
what else has he been coming from an
actor yeah bad teacher let me see your
cream
you're a creature he's great and bad
teacher he's funny i mean
oh yeah
cameron diaz made the made him like no
cameron
diaz didn't make the movie the the the
red the redhead
yeah yeah she's good
she was not super bad she
about the girl from uh easy uh actually
no emma stone
emma stone though no lucy
there it is amy squirrel lucy punch what
was she the girl you're talking about
and ella enchanted ellen but she was in
something else as well though she's in a
lot of
things pretty hot she's a british actor
correct yeah yeah
there she goes she's so good she's she
kills it yeah she makes the movie
yeah i like when he's taking a he's
like you know this is not the time to
bother
me she leaves me she blows it up
he's like you know this is my daily dump
wait this is not time
back to his acting you don't with
justin timberlake's acting he's not no
you're he's pretty good yeah you
know what your problem is about he's
coming out
you're coming at big sean justin
timberlake you're talking about two guys
who were
cemented in their lane
hold on that's why i got already jt is
cemented
in music huh acting no big sean
is cemented in having a record deal
music no
so i want you to i want you to
understand that you know you know
uh you're crazy you're talking about
justin timberlake's also the voice
of the head troll and one of the biggest
animations of all time called trolls
my biggest animation is one of trolls
he's the voice of trolls well i can you
can build you could do a voiceover
you can do a voiceover like i'm back
there i thank you
i was just on a set movie set this
weekend and i know what it takes
uh movie set or xbox commercial well you
have to say that to the audience
i don't know right commercial movie set
live
like like you're on alpha dog yeah
was in the social network oh it wasn't
social networking
yeah he's so good enough he's good in
that
bro he's the owner of us uh uh space uh
or uh
napster napster that yeah i guarantee
yeah
yeah if you see justin timberlake acting
in the like
any kind of movie oh i gotta go see it
now that's all i'm saying and the fans
would agree with me on this
what do you mean i think he's good yeah
he he's okay but the alpha i know i
thought he could have didn't get her
that's what i'm saying
who are you comparing you know you are
you know what you are you're the hater
online you're the kid who can't get into
the club
hating on the people in the club waiting
in line night after roxbury did
chris brown say that and
yeah you why you you're that guy look at
me now that's not me that's not me
that's you right now that's me just
saying like he ain't even good he's like
calling hold miami's what are you what
are you saying
yeah yeah what's the podcaster comic
talking
oh my god what's the guy with 20 000
followers talking about
i got more than that it's growing thank
you fans but but i'm saying okay
i'm saying i didn't like him in alpha
dog okay i'm just i'm saying
it don't matter bro you tripping he's
good crazy he's a beast was that his
alpha dog
first roll no it wasn't his personal i
don't know it wasn't his first video
god he was good i knew him up dude
it's a great great that's crazy that
it's a true story break your heart the
guy from the uh what's he got the girl
next door
uh email oh yeah
you want to compare it to that that
guy's that guy's a good actor i'm just
saying what was his first role it said
something that just made it on to uh
hold on he was a disney kid though yeah
he was like him and ryan gosling
yeah they grew up right now and uh
his first role he would go right here
that boy got credit credit
shut up he was in this since he was
a kid malik
well hold on oh in time that
movie's good he did the music i think so
let's see
he's the main character in time you
remember oh in time when uh with the
time oh yeah amanda seyfried was in it
again
it was okay the wonderful world of
disney
jason the simpsons i was a voice simpson
voices like look long shot i remember
that he was a valet that was my ice cube
i remember that
that one john give me something good
his own music videos yeah i'll finish
his first major role yeah first major
role okay 14 years
after his like chrono album he
didn't know what he was doing i get it
they said this went straight to the uh
video release edison
okay then after that he would oh he was
in black snake mold shout out to samuel
jackson
oh that one yeah remember that shrek i
forget he's in shrek he's a shrek he was
singing
no he's not sitting on there he's a
voice on track he's he's the prince
the lonely island dick in the box he
said love the love guru take it in a box
he got credits oh yeah he did a lot on
snl
too he did wait what he did a lot of
sketches on uh snl oh friends with
benefits friends with benefits
and you know she's married to ashton
kutcher and they came out with
the other they were on the 70s show but
that same year they had another like
friends with benefits
movies just go with wait no it was with
uh natalie
reported portman yeah i forgot what that
one was called but it's this and she did
it with ashley good job
yeah that's so funny and time was so
great
ashley kutcher was with demi moore for a
minute yeah the older women baby
come on man you know is that much is did
they have a huge age gap
yeah yeah huge yeah yeah that's what
inspired me to talk about 70 year old
yes yeah yeah her dollars she's not 70.
no that's inspired me to go to my
68 68 year i mean you can't just sit
here when you hate on not just to really
i'm not you know what you know what
you can't do that you can't do a dog did
you almost fire your mouth
what you mean i was trying to think what
beanie siegel said to uh
to charlemagne oh when uh that he was
like you don't he's like you're not
qualified you're not yeah you do your
google's qualified oh you know
he's like you're not qualified
i remember that yeah catches a fate he's
like you're not qualified he gets so
heated
that looks crazy and when you think why
shot him be quiet
what's up what's up everybody what's up
man
because the incident that occurred like
i said
ain't nobody right mind going stand
straight in front of me go to the
last minute of it that's when he gets
real heated uh-huh you're writing no
personality man
you don't come from my world you just
kind of like talking about it
[Laughter]
you shouldn't it's dangerous it's
dangerous
no doubt you talking muscles
he's not even scared he's accused of
murder during the height of my career
you should have been your job is to play
games shouldn't he shouldn't
be safe man don't play with me
and he set up i know that's why i know
he was for real because when you adjust
your seat
cause you're there you're not qualified
you're not qualified you're not quite
from my world remember sticky fingers
gotta charlemagne cause i mean through
your googles b
i did it
you know sticky fingers is right no is
either cross side dude or
no no no sticky fingers is the the bald
head guy he was in a lot of movies she's
a rapper as well onyx
onyx yeah yeah oh god i got it
troublemaking has been threatened so
many times so many times i've
been beat up i love it
i love you put it on video i love how he
trolls people that's so funny
is he a troll he's a troll or is he just
like i think he's just a no
type of like
yeah he is he's gonna like what people
are uncomfortable asking
because his boy and his group is
cross-eyed oh yeah
yeah yeah you talking about what that's
not cross-side now or cock-eyed all
right
right now
what's my man name in the middle yeah i
always thought i don't know i can't even
think his name yeah
they gonna kill him um you ain't no i
don't think he's a troll
i don't think he's trolling i mean no no
he just asked like what would like i
think he just asked
the questions the uncomfortable
questions
the is that no one wants to be
asked oh i watched uh schultz special
oh you finally watched it it's great huh
yeah it's not it's not like a comedy i
think if people are tuning in
like a comedy it's not a comedy special
that's more of like
a comedy it's more like monologue
like like current events like the daily
news with with yeah feels really good
oh dude he does really good jokes out
crushes it yeah
it's really good i i really i really
think he's doing his actual special in
two years
yeah yeah i think it's just a i mean if
people haven't watched this it's just a
good eye-opener
when it comes to all the that's
like costly going on
in this world it's gonna be hard
for anyone to come after him because
everybody gets it
everybody gives it everybody yeah
i love it because most people don't
think like that they just think for one
one side you know did you watch
it
i watched the first one i got i got
three more yeah i was busy i was filming
this week oh yeah there's four parts
are you filming uh was jt on set no jake
you ain't got time for that
come on it's premiering i don't know
much
xbox would have to pay jt to go on
that's a big deal it's premier no
my commercial is jt performing at the
super bowl yeah he was the halftime show
yeah halftime show
i'm not going with janet jackson titty
i'm sure well damn it that was so
disrespectful now two how's that
disrespectful
guys what happened the head of xbox said
they're gonna fly me to the super bowl i
just wanna let you know
bro that's what we're gonna talk about
we're in talks no we're not in talks but
here's the thing i don't want them wait
wait it's premiere doing the super bowl
they make beg
justin timberlake to go to the
super bowl they'd have to pay him to go
to the super bowl
yeah true well well if xbox commercial
is premiering
the date you're gonna go to super bowl i
don't know if they're gonna have fans
there
you see that yes it is in february yes
this is in february
where's the super hot this year next
year chen they said somewhere
i should know about but uh it happened
but yeah awesome how about that when i
get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just read a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son